this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app do you
want to get five dollars and also give
five dollars to charity of course you do
because you're a good person do you want
to buy and sell Bitcoin instantly or get
your paycheck deposited right into the
app then you got to use the cash app I
use it all the time I actually used it
today and all the babies rightfully so
are you downloading the cash app which
is why it's the number one finance app
in the App Store so download the free
cash app for iOS or Android mr. go man
we're in episode 64 and congratulations
here we go my babies I'm you know got
back from let's see where was I don't
know what I'm gonna be doing I'm gonna
be wet every time I do this episode
every time I probably do new episodes
now I'm gonna be doing by the way I'm
live on the first 10 minutes of the on
my app only for the subscribers this
time so you're getting a sneak preview
of the episode that's coming out
tomorrow which is now if you're
listening to it no matter what but I was
I'm gonna be doing because I want to
follow the leader tour which is my tour
and I'm doing a lot of a lot of the
roads so I will be on the road a lot
coming back from each episode each each
week I'll be saying like hey I'm back
you know I won't have just be like I've
been in LA so I was in let's see what
did I do I hit Pittsburgh which was
great and then I went to Cleveland and I
did a show for the students at some
university that's a case something
University you know one get one get rid
of knows it and and and then I went to
Dayton which was cool and you know we it
was it was really good it was a nice
little III was it always trips me out
how close Pittsburgh is to Cleveland and
that's why the rivalry makes sense but
two hours away it's like it's like
sitting in LA traffic to go to the beach
that's how [ __ ] that's how close it
is
but Pittsburgh was cool all of all III
hit Pittsburgh and then I hit Cleveland
so Pitt Pittsburgh was like ah you're
going to Cleveland I'm sorry
and then Cleveland was like hey sorry
you were in Pittsburgh like you know and
then when I got to Cleveland people said
hey sorry they said sorry sorry why they
said were worried I said Pittsburgh they
said why I said you know that's what
they said when I said I was coming to
Cleveland and slammed you and I did a
secret slam but it was what we call an
inquisitive slam because I was like did
you know that they said about that like
I was I put it on you it was an
inquisitor
talk about slamming though dude I was on
a the flight back and I was slamming
people left and right on Twitter dude
cuz I get bored you know daddy gets
bored when he's on when he's on the road
and he's on the on the plane he gets
bored you know he's always sitting next
to a [ __ ] 65 year old man he's got
nothing in common with cuz he's a young
buck he's a young buck you know he's
very young he's he's he's you know he's
he's made a name for himself but he's
still young he's still climbing he's not
the top wolf yet he's the wolf right
under that top wolf looking up at that
wolf being like I'm still hungry
right I don't know what [ __ ] proverb
that is I think Arnold Schwarzenegger
probably said it on pumping iron or
something it's better than coming I get
to come every day have you ever seen
pumping iron we're on a short short
snorts and Egger is like our
Schwarzenegger is like it's bet isn't
coming you I'm coming in every day we
get the palm but it's better than coming
I get to come every day I get to come in
the morning I get to come into night
every time I work out I'm coming ah
governor became governor you know why
didn't anybody who was running against
honor for scigirls' governor just say we
can't have Arnold Schwarzenegger
governing [ __ ] California and then
and then black and white this is why and
he just says I come every day we can't
have Arnold Schwarzenegger as the
governor of California here's why it's
about
coming I'm coming everyday I'm coming in
the night are your kids safe with Arnold
Schwarzenegger governing California I
come in the morning it ain't safe think
safer and safer and safer and safer and
safer and safer and safe it ain't safe
it ain't safe it's pretty safe okay hey
GZ it's pretty safe by the way I'm gonna
call him DZ cidade humor you guys like
DZ yeah you heard this rap rock easy
yeah the kids like DZ it ain't safe then
it's a pretty safe in and safe hidden
safe in its they've been and safe didn't
say yeah it's safe it's fine
it did say for the black for the white
girls and it's safe it's safe hidden
safe it's safe it's safe it's safe
I don't mention Asian girls I don't
mention the Indian girls only little
black ghetto white girls and it's a
pretty safe it's a fairly safe written
Inger's is safe so anyway I speaking of
Arnold Schwarzenegger the day before I
left for the follow-the-leader tour in
the Midwest edition Pittsburgh Midwest
edition I heard I just was trying to
fall asleep cuz I had a [ __ ] one of
those ungodly early hour flights was
like a [ __ ] early o'clock cidade
humor and it was Oh dark thirty
yeah dad humor and too when I was a kid
my [ __ ] friend when my friend who
ended up dating the girl I was dating
him backstab me he thought it was so
funny that one time somebody said Oh
dark thirty two for it to be early in
the morning and then he ought it was so
funny and I don't never thought it was
funny and I've literally said I've said
it since even though I don't think it's
funny so anyway uh I turned on the TV
because I couldn't sleep because I knew
I had to get up in like three hours you
know you have to do that [ __ ] you're
just like come on buddy come on and then
you just turn on the TV and Terminator
was on the original one
and I I it's been so long since I've
seen that movie that I just was like I
let myself watch it again and it's so
good that movie is so good and so I was
like I'm gonna watch the second one I'm
gonna download the second one and
download the third one and so I did that
and I watched him on the plane the
second one is uh you know even better
the second one is all the best movies of
all time you know especially when it
comes to like futuristic robot [ __ ] or
like action even or whatever the third
one then I watched on the way to
Cleveland and that it's so weird totally
what happens to a movie when a director
stops doing it and then another director
tries to do it like James Cameron is is
an amazing director and I ever directed
the third one it was just not the same
you know and it was like Claire Danes
was in it and and and Nick Stahl was in
it and and they're great actors but it
just seemed I don't know it seemed off
you know like casting that guy Patrick
what was the guy who put the t1000
Robert Patrick like that was such a good
choice you know and like but it was like
off beat it wasn't like a he wasn't a
star
he was just like him the guy that they
wanted to cast and he was perfect and
they tried to cast some supermodel for
the turn they called her the terminate
tricks pandering and she was like so hot
and in the first ten in the first ten
minutes in the movie like the cop pulls
her over and she makes her own titties
bigger because she sees a Victoria's
Secret ad hey that's when I [ __ ] was
like oh come on I rolled my eyes on the
plane I went I broke the third wall to
nobody and I went look at this Hey she
made her titties bigger because she saw
a Victoria's Secret ad and it said what
is sexy and the cop came up and she was
and her titties went hey terminate
Rick's sexual dude and she had this red
leather outfit on the whole time like
blend in they blend in it was
supermodel that they they cast man she
was [ __ ] badass though she could
that's the thing dude
when you make the best one and then you
just try to up like she would like like
the t1000 first of all getting into
dorky territory but the t1000 was the
kind of person was the person was good
as a robot was there was a liquid metal
and our force thing I was like he is
more advanced than me he's liquid metal
how he's liquid metal AHA yeah yeah and
then and then he was like and then and
then they were like well how do we the
studio heads were like well we don't
have James Cameron well how do we make
it to the be the [ __ ] how do we make
it be the [ __ ] and they were like well
how about if she could also shoot
weapons and stuff oh yeah and then was
like she was making her armed
flamethrowers and buzz saws and it was
the same movies a second one only more
that's like what franchises do to try
that and then it was just not I wasn't
into it but I'm gonna watch the [ __ ]
rest of him I'm gonna watch number four
and number five and then James Cameron's
coming back for number six he didn't do
any of them and and this is what I love
about to [ __ ] franchise they made
they tried to reboot it and do number
four and it didn't really do as well as
I thought the one with Christian Bale
that was like that where he flipped out
on the scene and the on the set with
that what it was the [ __ ] thing you
were saying know what was saying good
good for you just I agree with Christian
Bale but he flipped out that flip out
thing was so funny dude
and and so then that didn't really do as
well as I thought then they wanted to
reboot it and they did it with a [ __ ]
the girl from was that Game of Thrones
and then that was just apparently at
panned and so they another they're like
[ __ ] it and that James Cameron was like
you know what I'm just actually gonna
make the third one he's doing now the
[ __ ] third one that's so [ __ ]
that's by the way that's that is the
most boss move I've ever heard of all
time he's like yeah go ahead run with
make the money I'd pay me for the
[ __ ] thing I'll be the [ __ ]
overseer I'm not really doing it go
ahead and make your [ __ ] silly little
movies and then one day he was like
gonna make another Terminator gonna make
number three [ __ ] the ones you made
uh-huh
that's so baller
that's so [ __ ] hilarious to me you
know what it is dude
you know what it [ __ ] for real is
that's what it is that's what it is when
they're like when they're like when he's
like hey so James Cameron we'd like to
make tt3 and he's like let me think for
a second Nick that's what he did oh let
me think real quick you know what give
me a moment just to think of that man
and then and then they were like okay
well can we do it anyway and he just
goes like this
pammi and then he as he likes
was that siren alive that skate where he
lights a cigar with a [ __ ] hundred
dollar bill that's what he was doing and
then he was like and then he was like
and then they're like okay okay cool and
then they made it and it didn't it did
fine
and they were like we should make maybe
a fourth one and he goes like this next
I'd make it pay me and then they were
like will we make a fifth one can we
reboot it's like I make it but pay me
and they were like okay and then it
didn't do that well and then and then
one day he just calls up whoever the
[ __ ] is doing the movie like the
production the [ __ ] studio hello hey
it's Cameron we're making number three
[Music]
and they're like uh okay yes camera
yes ma'am camera whatever you say and
then he's like okay cool and they're
like it's just and then and then they're
like is is like is it gonna be about
John Connor or is gonna be heavy is it
gonna have the Reese KY in it or
whatever and he just goes like this mm
let me think think think think think
thinking if you'd like to make a call
please hang up and try again message see
12 you know James Cameron gets so many
[ __ ] it's unbelievable while
watching his movies and cries cries
while watching Titanic and then and also
get so many [ __ ] while watching
other people's movies that aren't
comedies and laughs at them so hard
until he's laughing so hard that his
like tears are coming out of his eyes
and and anybody's getting [ __ ] and
he's just like oh like watching movies
that people think are good and like
we're critically-acclaimed and he's like
[ __ ] knows good and hasn't sincerely
hasn't also even though he's getting
[ __ ] hasn't had an orgasm since 1997
like gets recreation overhead light and
watches sci-fi movies that people
thought that people think are good like
watches The Matrix and and especially
the third one like revolutions and he's
just like well he's getting sucked and
the car goes in hits the [ __ ] you
know where it hits the twins or no hits
neo and then after the blow he's like
okay I'm done sweet because he doesn't
have an orgasm and the gaim cons huh I'm
come on the studio I just got inspired
hey [ __ ] heads
we're doing number three oh really Jim
Cameron is it about John Connor
[Music]
and then only responds to email to their
studio from then on Beth isn't coming
nothing and coming how many times also
were they trying to read redo the line
I'll be back
like the first time they did it I'll be
back and then the second time they did
it and he's like I'll be back or no it's
gonna be said I'm back and then the
third one when the terminate ryx is
coming he says she's back dude
the I mean no doubt in the fourth line I
didn't see it but he's gonna say they're
back hell and then the fifth one he's
literally looking at someone's back and
he says he's back hey I mean come on
dude make up new hasta LaVista baby oh
and in the third one he isn't even
taught this but he looks at a clerk and
he says talk to the hand
but they're good you know that's it's
it's like their pop you know the pop the
first two were actually really good the
third one was a popcorn movie whatever
um but it's all good it's all good I
just feel like
I don't know hey what's the did you get
the email from the the guy from San
Diego remember you sent me that send me
that again because I want to read that
on the podcast I was so funny so uh
anyway by the way enough about
terminator let's see I was talking about
the Starbucks arrest and everyone's like
boycott stop this is what outraged
culture is okay so some [ __ ] racist
person who works at Starbucks now they
call because these two black guys are
hanging out not purchasing anything at
Starbucks which is the meeting place in
all of America if you gotta meet
somebody say me man a Starbucks
okay you go and you wait and and so they
go do this and they I'm sorry I'm
getting something cued up because I'm
gonna do it [ __ ] stupidest joke later
anyway and they go to this Starbucks and
this this racist employee calls the cops
and the cops arrest these two black guys
just for hanging out they were waiting
for somebody and while they're getting
arrested the other guy shows up and he
was like what the [ __ ] going on I was
they were waiting for me and her like
and and whatever it's completely it's
definitely racist it's it's racial
profiling and it's it's terrible okay
and yeah I understand that
there's a whole system involved where
it's you know racism is a problem it's
not it's not just this one person that
does this but people are saying that are
like bully caught Starbucks boycott are
all Starbucks this is this is the
problem with what the outraged culture
is that it's not Starbucks fault it's
it's genuinely not Starbucks fault it's
this person is fault now I get you know
to clip up a racist out of a that that's
not doing anything you've got to get to
the root of the problem but saying there
were people online on I put out this
tweet what was it I put out this tweet
that was just don't you know it's not I
wrote
people people just don't listen on
Twitter too they just don't listen on
Twitter I said why are they why are
people saying Starbucks is racist it was
the one it was that one employee who was
racist it's not like Starbucks tells
them to arrest black people they just
serve terrible coffee be mad at that
okay like Starbucks can't be in control
of everybody's mind that works for it
obviously they don't want to hire racist
people III mean unless I'm completely
wrong and the head of Starbucks is is
Stacy Keach from [ __ ] American
History acts and so I was saying that
and somebody wrote me why do you feel
it's important not to make larger
connections about systemic racism and
instead keep it solely about
interpersonal interactions what's at
stake for you and not acknowledging the
issue is larger than one manager and I
said it sure is bigger than one person
but that's that is not Starbucks fault
if you think it is then you're a problem
not me and then I wrote to the same
person oh wait you have those short
bangs and [ __ ] now I get why you're
saying this because of course you had
those [ __ ] short as bangs but it's
like it's like it's so it's such a
liberal thing where they're like oh I'll
[ __ ] I'll make I'll make it I'll make
it about the biggest possible issue I
can I could like [ __ ] [ __ ] my pants
and people and a liberal would be like
well you know the problem is in our food
and you're like no I just
I should have got it to a bathroom no
the problem is in the companies that
provides our food how liberal can you be
I get that there is a systemic race
systemic what the [ __ ] is the word
systemic racism but like Starbucks isn't
the system in place making people racist
it's larger than
Starbucks so when I say as a comedian by
the way making a joke about how bad
their coffee is and then people and then
someone else is like what did they say
well you're saying systemic racism isn't
a problem
I said the four times it was a problem
here why are you so mad about this and
not the fact starbucks [ __ ] up
starbucks didn't [ __ ] up they didn't
[ __ ] up I wrote because Starbucks didn't
[ __ ] up I'm mad about outraged culture
it's so annoying an awful fire that
scumbag who called the cops you're
trying to go to [ __ ] in Starbucks and
[ __ ] you can't because I got to stop
doing these [ __ ] music here's their
never up on time I wanted to [ __ ] do
it the thing about how you can't go to
Starbucks because whatever dude you get
the raw [ __ ]
hey how about how music leaders have a
psalm 122 million views dude who watches
music videos on YouTube who's doing that
I got you know what I get kids I guess I
don't know I don't [ __ ] know I I like
I like I here's the thing I like get it
I'm not talking about the Starbucks
again I want to go back to terminate her
[ __ ] I like movies that nailh I like
movies here's the thing I like sci-fi
movies my buddies talking about Star
Wars Star Trek I don't I can't [ __ ]
watch Star Wars Star Trek okay to me
here's what I figured out I like the
movies that are about things in the
future that I could see happening I
can't like a movie I was telling this to
the group chat
today star start Star Wars dude like I
don't want it here how come every
[ __ ] movie that's a like a sci-fi
[ __ ] or a like a Lord of the Rings
type or our Star Wars they always have
the scene where like there's a [ __ ]
older guy who's like either alien or
some [ __ ] that's got like a cape and a
[ __ ] staff and and and and the
younger guy has to go to this [ __ ]
guy with the staff and the guys like
well when there's good versus evil good
is the hard thing to do evil is the easy
thing to do
so being good is hard work and the young
guys like oh and they go to this guy
with the [ __ ] staff I don't if I
would never watch a movie and a guy
shows up with a staff I'm out I'm out of
the [ __ ] movie dude I can't watch his
[ __ ] movie always a guy talking about
good and evil with the staff and a cape
and a [ __ ] he's half alien or some
[ __ ] and he's always in a large room
with it with a with a with a comfortable
as [ __ ] chair right like a large domed
ceiling thing with a big [ __ ] window
that sees either scrolling Hills or
outer space and he's just like breaking
it the [ __ ] down and he's got the comfy
ass chair by the way the rooms got
nothing in it but that big-ass comfy
chair who the [ __ ] would want to be in
that room if this guy who's knows
everything and it has all the money in
the world or whatever the [ __ ] goods and
gets [ __ ] sucked off left and right
why the [ __ ] is he gonna be alone in a
room with a comfy chair and that's it
the guy doesn't have satellite TV maybe
sometimes he's got like grapes and
cheese near him but that's it if I can't
stand movies where there's a character
with a guy in a staff that's what I
broke it down to and he turns around and
he's always in the preview too and he
turns around and he's just like well you
know good and evil and time-travel and
if you put a vest with a bunch of
pockets on it
take a hike put on a vest with a bunch
of pockets and take a [ __ ] hike how
many things you need to bring when
you're hiking you know the vest with all
the [ __ ] pockets on what do you bring
it a compass a phone a [ __ ] a canteen
that clips on it anyway you're not using
the pocket
those were the string of texts that I
was sent into the [ __ ] I'll just read
them this is what I was saying and I try
I I wrote any movie where there is some
super [ __ ] super knowledgeable older
nah I draw any movie where there is some
[ __ ] super knowledgeable older alien
man with a cape on that walks around
with the staff [ __ ] blows elephant
[ __ ] til the cows come home and then
one of the people wrote hi and then I
wrote or honestly any character with the
staff [ __ ] movies with people who use
staffs it's not Noble it's not good I
wrote [ __ ] I hate that any time some
movie wants to beat you over the head
with some [ __ ] good versus evil
thing they give some guy a staff and
make him say it all slowly and [ __ ]
I wrote interior huge floating vessel
nighttime always a guy with an old staff
humans are evil by nature it is harder
to do good that's what separates the
weak from the strong a lot of music cut
a lot of music plays then cut to a lot
of scene as seen with lasers and then I
wrote and why do they have to sit in a
big lonely chair yeah those characters
always just have some big-ass lonely
chair they are sitting in a huge room
who the [ __ ] would want to do that is
boring as [ __ ] just sit in some big-ass
echoey room with nothing in it and wait
for some [ __ ] to come in that needs
advice about good and evil yeah do it
for real I agree with me I always
oh and then I wrote out of literally one
minute later I always wait for the food
to come out to fart on the plane it's
amazing how much food smells like farts
if you think about it you ever do that
food comes out and you're like dude when
food comes out imagine it's farts it's
all I'm saying
mind blown god I don't fart I don't I'm
kidding about that but like farting on a
plane to some gangster [ __ ] farting on
sub-game some plane part farting on a
plane and raising your hand enjoy the
fart particles yeah I I was every time I
walk around let me do an ad break first
did you get your babies oh [ __ ] uh-huh
hey guys have you heard of a little
thing called a harmony cuz it's a big
thing alright if you're if you've tried
or you're trying online dating chances
are you've run into lazy text messages
dead-end conversations random matches
that don't turn into dates alright
well guess what we developed a profile
on eHarmony and we did it for one fire
and we're gonna see how it goes with him
and I was with him we were creating his
profile and it was really easy and fun
we made a nice low profile for him and
we're gonna see how it goes for him so
hey if you're on eHarmony maybe you'll
you'll match with one fire who knows
love is in the air you know but heed
harmony take steps that other dating
sites don't in order to find you a more
compatible match I mean it's built to
help you find lasting meaningful
relationships it's not a shallow hook-up
site like some of the other ones
and they have helped over a million
people find their perfect match dude
that's a lot of people that's also cool
it also love enriches your life man when
you find a partner and you love them
this is this is 2018 I don't know
anybody that doesn't meet anybody online
this is the way to do it because it's a
real thing like I said it's not a
hook-up site er me uses decades of
science data and psychological research
to send you the right matches eeeh
harmony brings compatible people
together now right now my listeners can
get a free month with you harmony when
they sign up for a three-month
subscription enter my code Congrats at
checkout stop waiting and start your
journey journey to a satisfying
meaningful relationship it can be fun to
play around with online dating apps but
when you're ready to fall in love with
someone and have a meaningful
relationship there's only one app that's
built to bring you real love and that's
a harmony come see how e harmony can
change your life go to Harmony calm and
get started enter my code Congrats at
checkout square cash if you haven't
heard we've switched to the cash app
it's the simplest way to pay people back
friends family babies terminate trick
says sending and receiving money is
totally free and fast and most payments
can be deposited directly into your bank
account in just a few seconds and did
you know that the cash app lets you do
way more than that now you can even buy
and sell Bitcoin instantly get your
paycheck deposited right into the app
pull money out of the ATM with the free
custom cash card or use it to spend
anywhere you like you really won't find
a more useful finance app out there
I legitimately hand to God used it today
now when you download the cash app five
dollars goes to you and five dollars
goes to time's up Legal Defense Fund so
if you're passionate about that that's
really good and if you're passionate
about helping that's really good and
even if you're just trying to get points
with God it's still good
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now and I look I use it all the
time I use it above all the other apps
the other some of the other apps are
fine but this one is definitely the best
one it's the quickest you can do it over
texting
I did it over texting just today you
just go into the text field of the app
and you click it and you select a part
that however much money Oh somebody and
then you send it off so that's what's up
anyway so I uh every time I walk through
the airport on a Sunday I notice this
bugs me this bugs the [ __ ] out of me
okay and I don't even know if it's fair
that it bugs me or not cuz they can do
whatever they want through their own
company by the way here's what I believe
look when I I see I see the hustle and
bustle of the airport I see every store
open but chick-fil-a is never open on
Sunday okay now I want to give
chick-fil-a a ruby red [ __ ] you for that
now I don't eat chick fillet okay I
don't need chick-fil-a because it's
unhealthy that's it that's the reason I
made a decision a while ago this is
America and if a company supports
something that I don't agree with that's
as far as I go I go you know what [ __ ]
that company [ __ ] that company but if I
like the product look they can do
whatever they want companies it's like
free speech you're free to [ __ ] say
look I don't agree here's the thing
about the Roseann thing she voted for
Trump a lot of people are saying oh you
shouldn't endorse Wars and get her show
off the air that's not American she can
vote for whoever she wants to she can
vote for whoever she wants that she
could be outspoken for whoever she wants
she does not deserve to get her show
taken off the air because of who she
voted for and who she's outspoken about
that's the most on American thing I want
people to vote for who they want to vote
for I don't want people to vote for who
I want them to vote for I was never like
that man you know I want if somebody I
was always like that coming up with as
an open mic err I've never said hey can
I get on your show if you want me to be
on your show you'll ask me to be on your
show
you know guys guys bug me to open for me
hey don't bug me they asked hey Kai open
for you I'll ask you that's how I feel I
was talking about this with Hasan Minhaj
because we disagreed about it we did a
show together and we were hanging we had
some dinner mmm and he was bringing up
some good points he was like well I was
really shy when I was coming up and
people have said to me now that like you
know he was saying like now that he has
some sort of following people would say
like why didn't you just ask me to open
for me I would have loved it he was like
and I just was shy and I know people are
shy and that's a good point but still I
feel like if people will ask you like
don't it's only thing like if you're in
LA trying to submit for agents like
they'll just you'll get represented if
you're good and you work hard you will
that's how you know also it's working
you know I'm saying hey vote for me
Havel you know these [ __ ] breaking it
down to the dumbest level these chicks
vote for me Maxim's Hot 100 yeah I'll do
that hey chicks hey we'll use tweet my
link out I'm trying to get what you
trying to get it legit [ __ ] it I want
people to vote for me if they want to
vote for me I don't want to convince
anybody this where I can never run for
president I don't wanna convince anybody
they like me if they like me if you
don't like me put a vest with a bunch of
[ __ ] pockets on it take a hike put on
some [ __ ]
with some high socks get some [ __ ]
nice khaki cargo shorts put a bunch of
put a vest with a bunch of pockets on it
get a net hat and go near a river I
don't want I was always like that dude
if I'm dating someone and they're like
you know what I think I want to see
other people
case closed my hands are tied say yeah I
can't
it hasn't tied now Cass clothes go to
lunch I don't I'm not into it and that's
not to say if a girl I still if I like
the girl for I love the girl and she
does that it's still I'm heartbroken but
I don't want to be dude I've been in
relationships where they say oh I want
to be in an open relationship now and I
say oh well okay you know what am I
gonna convince you to not what you don't
want it you don't want it sorry the [ __ ]
Nara
I'm out donc I was with a girl
she was like I saw Oprah and she had on
somebody that had an open relationship
and maybe we should try that that was it
we I jumped off a building in my mind in
the relationship I jumped off the
relationship building I don't mean I was
like suicidal we I did my own stunts you
know life's too [ __ ] short although I
do like the bit where Chris Rock is like
life is longer than a [ __ ] cuz
it is cuz life is long dude they're all
made of moments that are very very quick
that's the thing
but life is long as [ __ ] and if you do
it right it's better than coming by the
way it was national [ __ ] sibling day
the other day hey days go [ __ ] yourself
when I see people post hey sorry almost
forgot
here's one of me and my brother national
sibling gay day okay national sibling
day hey sit on this bounce around a
little bit for those you're not watching
the podcast I got my middle finger up
got my middle finger up had [ __ ] mine
supposed to do that stick my eyeball
down turn it around was that [ __ ]
sticking out like a goon winging hand
with a more stump like national
almost forgot national sibling day all
dude you know what I was actually pissed
at you until you until you apologized
thanks for posting a picture with you
and your sis
when people say [ __ ] like that I just
want to go [ __ ] my mouth just to stop
them and have them be like excuse me did
you know it's national pizza day its
national sibling day is national hamster
day is national [ __ ] airmax day it's
national bald men Association day it's
national organ [ __ ] my mouth instead of
those days [ __ ] my mouth hey where's
[ __ ] my mouth day I want someone to [ __ ]
my mouth so I don't have to hear this
[ __ ] and I'll be traumatized over it but
chick-fil-a is not open on Sundays and
that's [ __ ] because I don't like
chick-fil-a though because they like
didn't the guy the head of the then he'd
donate to some anti-gay [ __ ] and then
he's like not open Sunday because of
he's a he's a like a Christian like hey
dude
hey welcome to backwards Ville that's
the most age-old [ __ ] that's the most
age-old problem there is is just is just
yeah I'm religious I'm Christian I love
everybody but also don't be this way and
a judge yeah but I love it but I love
you and you're going to hell but ya know
do what you want look you want to go to
hell all good just don't be around my
daughter like go [ __ ] yourself man how
about this I can't be religious until
that [ __ ] stops all that [ __ ] stops I'll
tell you what if all that [ __ ] stops
I'll buy a [ __ ] one of those big-ass
religious hats that looks like a [ __ ]
that just goes high up that Bishop swear
I'll walk around all slow every Pope
walks around so [ __ ] slow and I'm not
even telling you it like I know you like
all cuz he's old no it's not that
[ __ ] walk slow sand it's since
he walked how religious is it to walk
slow you ever seen a religious guy run
nah they don't run they don't [ __ ]
run at all they walk around all slow
taken in Christ
how religious is it to go take a walk
and talk with somebody would you like to
go get some fresh air who said that that
never believed in God nobody's ever said
that that hasn't believe in God would
you like to go take take a walk for some
fresh air talk about some sins are you
gay
okay let's go then I love everybody
I mean beard a national pet day national
make lunch count day national wear your
pajamas to work day these are all in
April look-alike day the [ __ ] out of
here you know there's a twins day to
[ __ ] you
picnic day imagine celebrating all of
these being the [ __ ] at work that's
like hey it's the 25th it's national
telephone day how about on the 30th it's
National honesty day that day I'm gonna
walk in to wherever I am I'm gonna be
like you're fat and they're gonna be
like what am I saying
it's a xxx haven't you heard it's
national honesty day jerked off today
say yeah I came in my bed before I woke
up today I was alone one small coffee
sir yes you need to leave
well it's national honesty day that's
have a point two guys come in that look
like each other you guys are you're on
the wrong day it's this is the 20th pet
day how basic that is [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
is it's Italian how basic at that [ __ ]
is every day's pet day every day you
walk around you see everybody with their
[ __ ] pets what is this
look at this what is this may go up may
world password day what the fifth is
Free Comic Book Day the state is the
sixth is Nurses Day the eighth is
Teacher Appreciation Day the ninth is
receptionist day which is like they were
like well I would do the teacher one in
the receptionist answer
xi is eat what you want day I mean where
do we live in [ __ ] North Korea you
can do that anytime in the fifteenth is
chocolate chip day 18th is oh no dirty
dishes day what oh I'm gonna making the
[ __ ] out
it's be a millionaire day hey hey guys
did you walk girl just uh it's it's my
day
why alliance be a millionaire day oh
dude be a millionaire day I think come
on dude [ __ ] start up turn over the
car drive by hey crash into hey that's a
[ __ ] drive-by ahead that crashed into
head be a millionaire day what kind of
[ __ ] do you have to be to
celebrate that I want to know if there's
be a billionaire day scavenger hunt day
and then there's hamburger day kind of
fat [ __ ] you have to be to celebrate a
hamburger day you know just some guy to
desk if you're a guy that celebrates
hamburger day you're a guy that eats on
his belly I mean
one fire just googled wimpy from Popeye
that [ __ ] always made me so
hungry every time he would eat burgers
he'd just toss them up and eat burgers
and [ __ ] that [ __ ] made me so hungry
always every time I saw wimpy eating
burgers buy the [ __ ] like they were
skittles I was so hungry every time I'll
gladly pay you Tuesday for a hamburger
today worst businessman or best the guy
would die at 22
how old was wimpy when he died he looked
old I know he never lived I get it one
fire looked at me weirdly I get it I
know why does it make me hungry though
yeah there's too many [ __ ] nice on
national sibling day the other day get
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you get out of your
[ __ ] and then same people who [ __ ]
post about that [ __ ] go to Coachella all
day long everybody is at Coachella
everybody's like oh tell her I'd already
did a Coachella rant I'm not gonna do it
again but like how about Beyonce talking
about she was like she's asking media
outlets not to post unflattering
pictures about her hey Beyonce this is
Earth hey Beyonce look around do you see
the houses do you see the hills do you
see the blue sky look down
do you see grass or dirt that's because
this is Earth and on earth there's the
Internet and when there's the Internet
there's shitty photos of famous people
ask Ben Affleck I can't think of Ben
Affleck without thinking of a flank but
yeah dude she I love to on Twitter
people were like well she can ask but
it's not gonna happen oh really
housewife oh really
a person well she can ask it's her life
but I don't think I think honestly
people are gonna it's gonna make it
worse
oh really
you [ __ ] two-bit tweeter um yeah dude
like what does she think it's gonna make
it worse I mean dude I'm naughty I'm not
I would have my 1 1 millionth is famous
as Beyonce there's pictures of mean I
know I'm a comedian so I take silly
pictures sometimes but there's pictures
of me that I'm just like oh no I'm
literally like oh if a girl I was
interested in wanted to date me and then
googled me and saw that picture she
wouldn't go out with me I need that
picture off of the internet now one fire
is googling pictures of me and pictures
of my ex-girlfriend are coming up and
that's an extreme one fire move but it's
all good
one fire one good one get rid of is
laughing in one fires face because even
one get rid of knows not to do that from
his Russian heritage but Coachella dude
Beyonce made his
this weekend as the first black woman to
head like Coachella isn't Coachella like
four years old how old is it
eleven is it really that old oh man I I
love I just love and hate the Internet
you know you got to do it you got a
faith I think what Beyonce should do is
post the unflattering pictures and be
like mother [ __ ] come at me
I know that's like my style but like and
it's not Beyonce style but also like you
just get older and you start looking
more and more like a potato that's just
what happens you know also she's I mean
dude she's moving her body like a
[ __ ] maleimide and I got snake
charmer what was that [ __ ] or Kelly
song or Kelly s is specific when he
makes music you remind me of my Jeep
sexist how come R&B can be so sexist
you haven't heard much about R&B though
this year that's probably why cuz RMB
people think it hip-hop is sexist and
country music sucks nothing more sex is
the army euro mommy of my Jeep [ __ ]
that's basically here a can't face here
amamiya my Jeep you're nothing you're
not good for anything but I can you
remind me I'm a jeep you've got four
wheels those are titties I mean number
one are killing me that [ __ ] 90 parts
song about being trapped in the closet
hat I mean Ark is there anybody who's
more of a nutjob than our Kelly by the
way that's my favorite [ __ ] song of
all time I don't give a [ __ ]
our Kelly was the [ __ ] Paul Simon of
R&B Paul Simon would sing that [ __ ] he
would just be like yeah walk to the
store one day no Walter so I talked to
the clerk and a [ __ ] drink some and
right-handers walking down there eating
man man
and and white people were like ah that
speaks to me and then our Kelly's just
like house drop in the cloud therefore
[ __ ] 50 minutes and white people are
like no it's the same thing our Kelly
has got to be the biggest nutjob
I mean he pees on fourteen-year-olds ah
that's enough but also his songs dude
look at this we googled it the first
thing that came up trapped in the closet
chapter 15 Hey
too many dude our Kelly how many times
open hand slapped a woman like for
asking a question and just been like
[ __ ] you don't ask me [ __ ] if you don't
know ask me [ __ ]
listen to the clock tick tick till you
get hit again right and the girls it's
like I don't know I control on you [ __ ]
just you remind me of a dog just pissing
on her I Archie Lee is such a lunatic
and nobody this is how much this is how
crazy our Kelly is nobody really talks
about how [ __ ] bad he is at life he
like Harvey Weinstein you just look at
him and you're like I will [ __ ] this guy
we're gonna take him down he's a piece
of [ __ ] our Kelly is insane that's how
you know he's insane cuz nobody's like
get our Kelly you know he needs to be in
jail because they're literally just like
I don't know what the [ __ ] to do with
him he pisses on fourteen-year-olds and
sings about being trapped in a closet
literally for 30 chapters or however
many chapters it was just sit insane
honestly that movie rampage I want to
see gorillas and alligators big
[ __ ] shits just fighting each
other and the rock dough in sign
language - an albino gorilla that's what
I want to say and I want to see it cuz
of the rock because he's a goddamn movie
star and he might be the only one left
and the movie didn't do as well as they
thought it was but it was still number
one because of the rock that movie is
not even rampage it's Dwayne Johnson in
rampage that's what that movie should be
called that guys that guys this [ __ ] I
read an article once we were like he's
the male Beyonce he is he's the male
Beyonce
that guy I love the rock god that guy
[ __ ] makes me laugh intentionally to
intentionally not ironically or
unintentionally like when he makes a
joke I go like this ha ha ha
the rock and I mean it he did it
ok mother-effer like when he does that
[ __ ] on instagram because he won't say
[ __ ] I go
keep it clean Rock yeah he's a bad
sumbitch he's a bad sumbitch isn't he ha
ha ha Kevin Hart is short ha ha ha [ __ ]
are the rock the guy's a [ __ ] the
guy's a [ __ ] oh oh and let mark my
[ __ ] words dude you don't think if
you don't think the rock is going to run
for president one day Europe
idiot what's the presidential song the
[ __ ] how's it go the that yeah dan tan
tan-tan tan tan-tan and thinning and the
rock comes out I'm gonna I'm gonna run
for president ha ha ha ha America you
son of a bees and let's be like oh [ __ ]
we just vote for him and it was a
composer oh yeah yeah we wrote for him
when I tweeted him once I wrote why is
the rock always posting why is the rock
always posing like this on Instagram and
I did that thing where he's like this
and then he tweeted me back cuz even my
nose hair are handsome some [ __ ] and
I'm showing them off and then he put in
parentheses or it could be I'm too lazy
to raise my arm any higher and that that
made my day because the rock is is my
favorite movie star
straight up I live for him he's great
he's great he is who he is he this is
why I like him he knows who he is and he
amplifies that that's exactly right
especially first of all it's right in
life it's especially right if you're a
[ __ ] movie star or in the
entertainment business or on stage as a
stand-up comedian the guy's great man
the guy's great I'm a huge rock fan I
love him I'll go see I'll probably go
see rampage I might go see tonight but
mark my words
dan dan 10 then it's an ant ant ant you
know when I did conan once conan said
this and then i did that
ha ha ha ha ha yeah he's cool man
he's a cool [ __ ] I didn't know
what a good time to talk about this was
on the episode but I wanted to bring
this up
I should hope I should have maybe opened
with it but it's a little bit more of a
serious thing and a somber thing and a
sad thing yeah but it means a lot to us
comics here
Mitzi shore passed away and Mitzi shore
passed away and it was a it was a weird
thing it was first of all it's a sad
thing because she owned the Comedy Store
and she created the Comedy Store and you
know for 46 years ago and it was a it's
it was and is the greatest place for us
as comedians to feel at home and to you
know she always made it a point to where
you could say whatever you want to on a
stage and not be judged and I always
felt that at the Comedy Store and I
don't feel that at all the other clubs I
mean I I make myself feel that way when
I'm doing the road and stuff like that
but at the Comedy Store it felt like you
were accepted for that for being
unapologetic in your stances and in your
comedy and they wanted that they wanted
you as an artist to be that way and I
learned a lot at the Comedy Store
because of that through mitzi and
through the people who ran the club that
were employed by Mitzi and I met her at
least once and she was just like this
this
did so much for comedy but she was like
this woman that that cared about it so
much and like I always say here if you
know you listen to this this podcast you
know I love when people are good and
care about what they do but she loved
finding talent and like nurturing
comedians and loved trying to spot
talent and you know she she told people
what she thought of them and she made
careers made comedy career she made
stand-up careers
happen and she was one of the people
that started something I can't I'm
paraphrasing this but I was reading the
other day about how she kind of like
helped birth Comedy Central in a way or
what has come to be known as Comedy
Central but without her comedy would be
a different thing
stand-up would be a different thing
today she's just like a legend in comedy
and I don't know if people who listen to
this podcast know that I know some of
you do because your comedy fans
obviously you listen to this podcast but
but people think of comedians as the
people that change the game for comedy
and oh yeah Richard Pryor and George
Carlin and whoever Eddie Murphy and you
know the guys now that are moving comedy
in the direction that it's moving but
but there's also the people that aren't
on stage that do that like Mitzi shore
and and I know others too but Mitzi
shore was arguably the most important
person who did who was that and she she
passed away a few days ago and you know
I knew her I met her like I said once or
twice she passed me I was one of the
last I was one of the last people that I
was actually the laughs the last person
that she passed I believe I was the last
person that she passed at The Comedy
Store that where there were showcases I
know she I know she passed one other
person after me but just because she
came to the club and saw him on stage
and was like put that person on the ROI
on the lineup a lot and that was just in
Martindale who's great but she just
hadn't like she would do that she would
just happy she would just see somebody
and be like put that person on every
single night at ten o'clock
and whoever was running the club would
be like really and and that person would
then become you know a big comedic star
and because she felt like oh she would
do stuff like
this person needs to open the show at
nine o'clock every night for a year
because she thought that that person
needed that in their journey or whatever
you want to call it or you got to give
this person late-night spots they got to
go on at 1:00 a.m. because they need to
talk to five people and become more
conversational whatever she would say
and she had ideas for every comedian and
she was like oh you know they said they
said they called or like the godmother
at the Comedy Store and I just look The
Comedy Store is my favorite place period
and it's my favorite building and I love
performing there and she made it that
way and she meant a lot to me and I you
know I she meant a lot to a lot of
comedians and I you know I think she
knew that but it was just it was just
her not and even though she wouldn't
come to the club a lot anymore because
you know in her last days last few years
she's really fragile in' and old and but
it was still a a weird moment for me I
can speak for me even though I I didn't
have many moments with her at all but
just knowing that she had had passed on
and it it made me feel sad and it made
me feel I mean I'm still figuring it out
you know but I sit and I think about it
and the Comedy Store and and and just
what she's done and how crazy it is that
one person can do so much and my heart
goes out to the shores and Paulie
because she's Pauly Shores mom I don't
know if people know everybody knows that
but you know I fortunately so far don't
know what that feels like yet to lose a
parent but that's that's uh it's got to
be the worst so my heart goes out to
Pauly I think he's dealing with a well I
mean I haven't
talk to him yet but you know he seems to
be active and being sweet on Twitter too
to everybody who's talking about it and
but we all we all as comedians loved
loved what she did and even the people
that didn't know her are like thankful
about her it's just it's just really
cool it's cool that there's somebody
like that and that comedians can can
have their moment where besides the fact
that they're always making fun
everything to just like you know be
serious about something and and and and
express to people how how much she meant
anyway I'm kind of going on and on about
this but I just wanted I wanted to
because she was a really important
person in comedy and she's and because
of that she was really important person
to me and she passed me at the club and
that meant I mean that's one of the
[ __ ] things in comedy that like
comedians would start be like I want to
Mitzi sure will she see me I mean was
she passed me do you think she thinks
I'm good enough and and that's just
that's just cool cool to me that that I
don't know
I appreciate that moment that that that
small moment that she gave me in my life
and made me feel accepted and I don't
know it's just a [ __ ] awesome thing
and so rest in peace or whatever they
say you know to to Mitzi shore and
thanks for what you did in comedy so
that's what I have to say about that and
much more probably but that's it I don't
know how to get back to silliness with
that after that but you know what we can
do is I don't have an elder I don't have
a oh I do have an IG actually but before
I do that let's do this
I'll read the email this guy so one fire
sent me this and he wrote I thought
you'd like this one now you guys I've
talked about how much I [ __ ] hate San
Diego and I mean it okay cuz it sucks I
live in Dex till the cows come home and
this guy writes me I don't know should I
say his name does it matter
Matt forget
a subject San Diego he emails one fire
this okay and then the message he says
hey a why so I already like this guy I
don't know if this is how I'm supposed
to contact anyone but [ __ ] it whoever
reads this one fire Ivan get rid of
doesn't matter it's absolutely not Chris
because slays E anyways I listened back
long ago and heard Chris's rant about SD
now I've been in SD for six years now
almost seven redundant detail
this is him saying this and I can't
agree with Chris more tell him that a
sandy Aegon said I'm so sorry for those
[ __ ] morons
a long time ago Chris posted on Facebook
Ashton where he should perform an SD and
I commented dude you should just stay
the [ __ ] home he may have even blocked
me now that I think about it but I meant
it from the bottom of my heart I saw a
Harlan Williams in SD a while back and
the heckled and they heckled the [ __ ]
out of him he's the nicest [ __ ] guy
and these [ __ ] pieces of goddamn [ __ ]
wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up if I were
Chris I would just stop performing here
because there's too many idiots I don't
go out to the bars anymore because of
them I really want to see Chris but I
don't want to deal with the sad humanity
of downtown SD on a weekend I saw bill
bird twice up at a casino in front of
California
I'm not kidding that's a real [ __ ]
City I would totally drive 30 minutes
north to see Chris and I know he can
fill that room don't let the idiots make
you sour to SD you have a lot of fans
here that will travel a little bit to
see you just realize I'm giving [ __ ]
advice to a professional stand-up
comedian like my piece of [ __ ] ass knows
what I'm talking about what an [ __ ]
you know anyway love you guys
love the podcast but a fan since TMP
episode one well Casey thank you for
your email I feel like Casey Kasem well
Casey thank you for your email this one
thank you for your honesty mail we love
what you said about San Diego and well
we totally agree well on that note
here's a little special song for you
[Music]
that [ __ ] made me laugh dude I was
laughing on fire Hey look one fire he
can get fired and Ivan get rid of we can
throw him out the window but these guys
know me man and when they send me an
email I read it because they know my
sensibility and my sense of humor so on
that note we'll take you out with a
banger shrewd
alright so oh I also have an IG which is
good and I found a [ __ ] good one
someone sent it to me let me let me do
it before I do the intro here we go game
tomorrow saved ones hey guys it's time
for the most [ __ ] up Instagram post of
the week there we go this one is okay
I'll just do the caption first this is
what she says I want you to really live
so so she's taking interest and giving
us advice to all of her followers and
she's got a lot of followers I think oh
yeah I want you to really live oh that's
so sweet of you dude I want you to
really live I want you to take
adventures and break your own [ __ ]
rules
she says [ __ ] so you know that she
means business
below your own mind stop living what you
think you should do and start feeling
what you should do requirements bank
accounts systems they are all [ __ ]
stop being a slave to the money
disregard all superficiality because
trust me it's not the answer nine times
out of ten people say this [ __ ] they're
literally writing a note to themselves
this way says loving life and all this
freedom with I guess this is a man I'm
not gonna say his name thank you for
being exactly who you are
there is no greater agony than bearing
an untold story with a
you go bu hey said stuff everybody has
been saying for years hey you're not a
philosopher and in the picture she's in
a [ __ ] I don't even know what it is
like a house with no walls and a window
looking out a window even though the
house is outside and she's looking at
the rear end of a horse
hey and we can't see her face and she's
naked Hey of course she's naked dude
what's wrong with everybody everybody's
a [ __ ] psychopath a legitimate
psychopath we developed Psychopaths how
do I do this how do I do that
we develop Psychopaths we develop
Psychopaths didn't lean in the name hey
guys hey world stopped developing
Psychopaths
all right look that's it we went over an
hour in ten minutes and you guys we had
a good time I know it was mostly me
doing all the heavy lifting and work but
you guys you came through and you listen
to the podcast and I'll tell you what
our numbers are grown and pretty soon
pretty soon we'll all be in that log
cabin in the woods or on the field or
wherever the [ __ ] we are but we
guarantee I guarantee we'll be sitting
indian-style and we'll be sharing ideas
and getting [ __ ] and sucked and
leaving living that hedonistic lifestyle
and honestly it's better than coming do
we do everything outros or what okay
it's better than coming square cache
have you switched yet
download the free square cash app enter
rewards code congrats and get five
dollars and give five dollars - times up
get and get it for and so you're a good
person so get it for iOS or Android now
follow the leader tour that's my tour
buy tickets on Chris D'Elia calm I'm
going to Huntsville Nashville Denver
Boise Eugene Sacramento Red Bank
Wilmington Wilmington
reading reading or reading I don't know
I would say reading reading Tulsa
Oklahoma Midwest City Oklahoma
Dallas Portland Hampton Beach
Mashantucket Houston Wichita Kansas City
Lincoln Reno Las Vegas and that's and I
got the third leg coming soon and
subscribe to the YouTube channel you get
to see me live doing this podcast not
live well I did it live but and download
the Chris D'Elia app if you want to see
on this [ __ ] I went live you get that
[ __ ] before it even airs and then
subscribe rate and review the show that
really helps us out it helps you know
grow the cult and develop more baby
video message video episodes go up
Tuesday's or Wednesdays watch my
specials go on Netflix share man on fire
share all the other ones and thank you
for listening babies you guys are the
best
it eats a fitting safe bedding safety
fitting safe that ain't a fitting Savior
so white and just remember I seriously
want to remember them coming